[Music]
[Applause]
dot com we make way for one of our
favorites the former nfl offensive
lineman
host of the ross tucker football podcast
westwood one nfl analyst
he'll be in buffalo on saturday night
afc divisional playoff game between the
ravens and bills that's on westwood one
and uh he was also on the broadcast for
the colts and bills wild card game
this past weekend ross thanks for
joining us what's the weather forecast
in buffalo
yeah it's going to be cold dan as you
might imagine and they're saying there's
a decent chance of snow
now only accumulating an inch or so but
lamar jackson
already talking about it he was asked
about it yesterday he said he's never
played in snow before
he doesn't want to play in snow remember
he's a south florida kid so
i think i already tweeted this morning
dan at ross tucker nfl
the first rule of snow football club is
never admit that you don't want to be a
part of snow football
i mean like lamar i think is a little
bit too honest like we know you don't
want to play in the snowman but it might
be snowing
saturday night so just embrace it and
have fun can you imagine by the way dan
if it does a night game in buffalo
raven's bill snowing i mean if it snows
saturday night it's because of god
realized it should snow saturday night
but i think i would be more concerned
about the wind in buffalo
than the snow because by the time you
play
you know you get going and i i don't
think that concerns you as much as the
wind would if
if i'm a quarterback uh you tell me
would you would you be more concerned
with the wind in buffalo if you're
uh you know the quarterbacks or if it
snows
yeah well it depends on how much snow
right i mean i was up there a few years
ago
when the bills played the colts and it
was like an
absolute monsoon of snow the whole time
it was like a blizzard
the entire game so that's a totally
different story it doesn't sound like
it's going to be like that
wind is absolutely more of a factor
although i'll say this dan
the bills cannot run the football and
zach moss now is hurt so if there's any
time i mean
i would have argued that the more
inclement the weather right whether it's
wind or snow or whatever i think that
plays into the ravens
hands you know the ravens the last six
games
have had the most rushing yards of any
team in a six game stretch
since the 50s i mean they've had more
rushing yards the last six games
than six nfl teams had the whole year
meanwhile the bills can't run into lick
so i think the worst the weather the
better it is for the ravens quite
frankly
yeah i thought that the ravens were
going to be the dangerous team that
nobody wanted to face because it almost
felt like
and you've done the research on this
you'd know better
something happened with lamar jackson
where maybe he came to the realization
i need to just go out there and be the
guy the previous year like i'm not a
pocket passer
i'm never going to be a pocket passer
but i need to go out there and make
plays and we saw that in the game
against the titans
he needed to make a big play he made a
big play and it changed the complexion
of the game
what is it that you've seen from lamar
that's different from say
the first three quarters of the season
well i think part of it
is what you said but i think the other
part of it is greg roman the ravens
offensive coordinator
he kind of changed i think he realized
that with no marshall yonda and ronnie
stanley getting hurt up front
their offensive line wasn't as athletic
you know they're bigger though
phillips is like 345 fluker's 350
so rather than trying to run a zone
scheme up front
they're doing a lot of the same
backfield action but it's more
gap scheme which means you don't have to
move as much it's more just downhill
and you know what else dan i know they
like mark ingram
they realize that jk dobbins and gus
edwards are better yeah
those guys are just better dobbins and
edwards are better they get
more yards and the scores have been
reflected i mean
they have gone on a stretch 34-17
against the cowboys 47-42 against the
browns
40 points against the jaguars these two
teams
the bills and the ravens have the best
point differential
in the nfl over the last six games when
people like you have been asking me
who might be able to beat the chiefs
i've said the bills or the ravens now
the chiefs i think benefit they only
have to play one of them because they
got to play each other first
we're talking to ross tucker the former
nfl offensive lineman and
he'll be on the call with uh westwood
one with the bills and the ravens
saturday night ross tucker football
podcast
what should the texans do with desean
watson
well they're not going to trade him um
that that makes absolutely no sense
they need to first get him to get in
touch with them and actually listen to
listen to what they have to say and you
know i hate to say it dan
but i would imagine that they're gonna
now hire a head coach
that is desean watson approved i i think
they'll probably
talk to him about it maybe give him a
few names and if they come down to a guy
or two they're gonna probably lean to
the one that
desean watson would prefer he is the
most important
person in the building if you have a top
10
franchise quarterback they get paid the
most by a lot
they're by far the most important it's
crazy
to me that he reportedly likes the enemy
then they were the only team that the
six that had openings
that didn't request an initial interview
with eric the enemy
the only team and by the way they asked
desean
for his feedback he said the enemy and
then they're the only ones that didn't
i mean it's almost like they went out of
their way
to say to sean we don't care what you
think you're the player
you just play like why wouldn't you dan
logically
even if you weren't gonna hire him just
interview him because your franchise
quarterback wants you to
i wouldn't have given him that power to
have a say so
but you did therefore you have to listen
to him i don't know if brady had any
input
on i'm going to take less money or
spread this out
i'm going to leave it up to coach
belichick to be able to decide who he
wants to bring in
we thought all along well that can't be
the case brady should have a say and
then the more i
researched it the more i found out brady
didn't have a say in who they brought in
here you're given desean watson who's
what 25
kind of not veto power but he's involved
in the process
there so houston created this they
should at least acknowledge
uh you know his input here
totally agree and by the way what you
said about brady and belichick
i think that's part of the reason why
brady's no longer in new england
and in tampa i think he just kind of got
sick of that i mean i think he got sick
of taking less
and then they weren't actually getting
better players for him what am i taking
less for
and i'm throwing it to an old edelman
and a bunch of guys that stink why am i
taking less
for you to put these guys around me
uh what kind of surprises you think
you'll see
you got one this weekend
yeah i don't know if it's a surprise but
um i think the ravens are going to win
saturday night and i think the bucks are
going to beat the saints so
look they're not big spreads we talked
about it on the even money podcast
it's like two and a half and three so
neither one of these would be
shocking but i just think the ravens the
way they run the football
i mean the colts should have beat the
bills the colts were the better team on
saturday
they just screwed it up multiple
different ways josh allen played
awesome and the bills still barely won
meanwhile the bucks are getting back
devin white and steve mclendon
brady's playing way better than he was
earlier in the year
and i think it's very difficult to beat
a team three times so
out of the underdogs the upsets i'll
take the bucks
as well as the ravens on the road
explain to me
aaron donald and how that
like the packers and aaron rodgers the
game plan you'll have
and how it focuses on aaron donald
so what's interesting about that dan is
i wonder how effective he's going to be
able to be
uh you know the reports are that he tore
rib cartilage
against the seahawks that is really
painful
i never had that happen but i've had
guys tell me
it's more painful than actually if you
crack a rib
if you tear that cartilage and so much
like if you see him he is so
twitchy and he's so explosive and he
contorts his hips
to try to get the corner on the guards i
just i don't know if he's gonna be as
effective
as he normally would be he's a guy
though i can remember
remember you probably don't remember
tommy harris when he played for the
bears
tommy harris had like a two or three
year run okay he was unreal
i remember playing for the browns dan
and even if we were supposed to slide
the protection the other way i was
starting at center
you were going to go one way we made a
deal andrews and cosy coleman
wherever tommy harris was we were going
to double team them and we all kind of
we
we all kind of made a pact that's the
pack you have to have with aaron donald
you have to have an understanding that
even if that's not what you're supposed
to do
you better do it otherwise somebody's
gonna get embarrassed
you have jalen ramsey on the back end
too so do you just say to jalen ramsey
devonte adams
is your friend like you you two are
gonna be together an awful lot the
entire game
and then you take your chances elsewhere
correct it's like hoosiers
and you got to know what flavor gummy is
at the end of the game
for uh you know what's weird dan i
really i miss on the rams
i did not think they were going to be
good if you look at their defense
it's there's no players in the middle
that it's aaron donald
20 something million a year jalen ramsey
20 something million a year
and a bunch of guys making the minimum
but they figured out
if you have two top 10 defensive players
in the nfl
you can kind of fill in the other pieces
as long as you have those two i was
skeptical but man
it worked and their d coordinator
brandon staley
that guy is a stud he should be a head
coach this year
yeah you're not alone in missing on the
rams because i did too because i didn't
know how good the offense was going to
be
then they get jalen ramsey you got an
offensive minded head coach
who then changed over to understanding
i'm gonna win with defense here and just
enough offense
before i let you go the browns and the
chiefs the browns win this by
doing what running the crap
out of the football and playing zone
coverage on defense
and not giving up anything cheap and
deep
but they got the best o-line in football
and
chubb and hunt are playing at a really
high level
they need to try to pound the chiefs
into submission
i think they have a shot i don't agree
with the betting line on that one dan at
all i said that on the even money
podcast
that is way too many points i think the
browns have a chance they've got a good
formula
and the chiefs haven't been able to put
anybody away or blow anybody out
in forever so i like the browns and the
points for entertainment purposes only
yeah i like the browns an awful lot
against the steelers
and so you don't have your coaches and
you go in there and
you know you blow them out i think if
the browns don't get full of themselves
which they have that capability of doing
it but hopefully kevin stavansky back
will you know make sure that doesn't
happen
i think if they do go in there with that
game plan they make it interesting
because
i have to keep my homes off the field as
long as possible
and i cannot let any one of those
receivers get behind me
you know and the chiefs they let teams
hang in there
ross i mean that's it's a fault of
theirs they do win but they let you hang
around
uh almost as if they're teasing you yeah
two thoughts on that
one is the browns are also getting their
best o linemen back joel betonio their
best defensive backpack
they should be getting back denzel ward
and you're exactly right you know
you talk to any of these math guys dan
the chiefs had
how many games in a row were they one by
one score or less
you're gonna lose one of those like they
almost would have been better off
if they lost to the falcons or they lost
one of those games earlier
because if they do that in the playoffs
against the browns
or the bills ravens or whatever they're
going to lose you the
the odds tell you you keep trying to win
these one score games
it's going to go against you one of
these times you're not going to get that
break like they did against the falcons
have fun in buffalo there ross always
great to talk to you
i will absolutely thanks for having me
dan and we don't have to have that
question
answered can lamar win the big one like
can he win a playoff game here
i know but you know dan what's going to
happen right if they lose saturday night
all off season can lamar win in the snow
can lamar jackson ever win a snow game
in his whole career
and this will be his first snow game so
hopefully
he shows out here thank you ross that's
ross tucker
the ross tucker football podcast and
he'll be on the call saturday night on
westwood one
with the ravens and the buffalo bill